hey everyone it's Warren and although we
do not have the spider-man far from home
trailer yet we do have some news to talk
about and break down right now the
release date for the trailer is
currently unknown but it is not expected
to drop this week it is however expected
to drop either on or before next weekend
so we can show during the premiere of
Aquaman this isn't confirmed but they
did rate the trailer which they normally
don't do unless they plan on releasing
it soon and the trailer was shown at the
Comic Con experience in South Paulo
Brazil last weekend so it should come
pretty soon and thanks to its showing at
CC XP we have a description of what is
shown in the trailer thanks to the fans
who are in attendance we got a good
description of what was shown but now we
have an even better more detailed
description of what to expect so I'll
break it all down for you I'm currently
giving away a life-sized Infinity
Gauntlet all you have to do to enter for
your chance to win is be subscribed to
my channel like this video and comment
down below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero so like I said we
have a more detailed description of
exactly what happens in the trailer the
trailer starts off with Peter Parker
Aunt May and happy Hogan and in the
scene happy is trying to flirt with Mae
Peter is going on a school trip with MJ
and Ned and while he's packing his
clothes he chooses to leave his
spider-man suit at home he wants to go
overseas and he wants to take just a
brief rest from his life as a superhero
so as I mentioned in my first video
about the trailer description they don't
mention Avengers infinity war or
Avengers in game in this trailer at all
so we're not sure if he's taking a rest
because of the events from Avengers
infinity war and Avengers in game or if
he's taking a break because of the
events that happened in spider-man
homecoming but despite where this film
picks up from he just wants to go
overseas as a normal high school kid
taking a school field trip and not have
to fight crime as a superhero so he
leaves a suit at home the group goes to
Venice Italy and they go and see the
canals and in this scene we start to see
a little bit of a romance developing
between Peter and MJ soon after that we
see Peter in a hotel room with Ned when
all of a sudden a mysterious person
appears and shoots a tranquilizer dart
at Ned of course it is the one and only
superspy nick fury fury needs
spider-man's help and is there to
recruit him for a mission and fury
brought along with him multiple Spider
Man suits including Peters classics
suit and a new stealth suit this is most
likely the first time that Peter and
fury meat because Fury wasn't there
during the events of civil war and he
wasn't there during the events of
infinity war either but we learned from
the Captain Marvel prelude comic that
director fury in agent Hill were
actually watching and monitoring all of
the heroes during the events of civil
war including spider-man
so Fury is well aware of who's
spider-man is and he knows that he's
Peter Parker we also know that fury and
he'll are again leading shield shield
was dissembled at the end of the Winter
Soldier but it was kind of brought back
at the end of age of Ultron it was kind
of left unresolved but we know that in
spider-man far from home shield is back
because in some leaked set photos we can
see spider-man wearing a suit that has a
shield logo on it again not really sure
what events take place between
spider-man homecoming and spider-man far
from home we know that there's going to
be time travel in Avengers endgame so
maybe the Avengers go back in time and
change a few things and now in the
future we still have shield again we
don't know the reasons but for whatever
it may be
shield his back and spider-man far from
home and Nick Fury is there to recruit
Peter Parker for a mission and again he
brought a stealth suit for Peter which
is designed to help him go about his
mission undetected and thanks to Cece XP
we got a really good look at the suit
and this description also says that one
of the uniforms that Nick Fury brought
with him is the classic spider-man suit
with the webbing under its arms which is
awesome I'm really looking forward to
seeing that in the movie then at the end
of the trailer we have what is described
as a breathtaking sequence
spider-man is fighting hydro-man and
Mysterio shows up and fights alongside
spider-man to help him defeat hydro-man
so like I said in my last video about
the trailer Mysterio is only pretending
to be a hero
Mysterio's goal is to get spider-man out
of the picture because he actually wants
to be spider-man
what Mysterio really wants is Fame he
wants to be this hero that everybody
loves so his goal is to take out
spider-man so he can take his place and
be the one that everybody loves and part
of his plan to do this is to make
spider-man think that he's actually a
friend that way he can blindside him and
I've actually said it before in previous
videos I actually think that hydro-man
and these other elemental enemies are
going to be illusions that Mysterio
makes himself so I actually don't think
that they'll be real they'll simply be
Mysterio tricking Peter Parker so he can
make him think that
a good gut although the trailer
description doesn't hint at it this is
the type of villain that Mysterio is
he's an illusionist so there is the
spider-man far from home trailer
description breakdown we shouldn't have
to wait too much longer for the actual
trailer to come out but let me know what
you think of the description leave your
thoughts in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to spider-man far
from home thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof
[Music]
you